Most film productions shoot far more footage
than we ever see, and the stuff we do get
to see on the big screen is usually there
for a pretty good reason.
But when the final edits are made, some deleted
scenes are sorely missed from the movies they
were cut from.
They might add extra layers to the characters
and their stories, provide humorous breaks
in dramatic action, or even give the audience
a fascinating new perspective of the plot
itself.
But these are not those scenes.
No, these cinematic mistakes were better off
left on the cutting room floor.
A dark turn
The Back to the Future movies were never supposed
to be anything but crackerjack, wholesome
family fun, so it’s easy to see why this
particular scene in Part III ended up in the
trash.
Early on in the movie, Buford Tannen's gang
face off with the local marshal and his young
son; after disarming the marshal, Tannen orders
him to leave town.
He does, but Tannen shoots him in the back
anyway, right in front of the boy.
“Pa!”
“Remember that word, son, discipline.”
While this might have been in keeping with
Tannen's ruthless, detestable character, it
would have been a shocking departure from
the trilogy’s lighthearted tone.
Ant-Man wins big
Scott Lang’s desire to turn away from crime
and become a suitable role model for his young
daughter Cassie was one of Ant-Man’s principal
character arcs, so it’s no surprise, then,
that this scene didn’t make the cut.
It featured Scott’s buddies Kurt, Luis,
and Dave indulging in a night out at a casino,
consistently getting lucky with the help of
a certain diminutive hero.
It’s an entertaining sequence, but given
Scott's steadfast insistence on turning over
a new leaf, it wouldn't have made a whole
lot of sense in the context of the movie.
Hadley's lost hope
In James Cameron’s 1986 masterpiece Aliens,
Sigourney Weaver’s Ellen Ripley returns
to the moon LV-426 to make contact with a
lost human colony.
Accompanied by a ragtag band of space marines,
Ripley finds the colony deserted and half-destroyed,
resulting in some of the Alien saga’s darkest
and most unsettling scenes.
“Nothing… not a g------ thing.”
The movie’s original cut, however, included
another scene which single-handedly put an
end to all the tension and terror of the abandoned
Hadley’s Hope.
Here, we meet the inhabitants of the colony
as they go about their day, complete with
lengthy, unnecessary static shots and a walk-and-talk
conversation between two characters which
adds almost zero substance to the plot.
We also meet Newt and her family, before the
scene concludes with the movie’s first appearance
of a facehugger.
All in all, it amounts to an arduous, useless
bout of exposition which would have drained
pretty much all of the suspense from the movie’s
terrifying second act.
Judgment revoked
The ending to Terminator 2: Judgement Day
is the perfect coda to a grim, thrilling sci-fi
adventure: the audience’s point of view
traverses a dark, mysterious road while a
weary Sarah Connor muses on the ambiguity
of the future, before allowing herself a brief,
final glimmer of hope for humanity’s fate.
James Cameron's original ending, however,
was a little less ambiguous.
We see an elderly Sarah sitting in a park
while an adult John Connor plays with his
daughter.
Sarah states flatly into a tape recorder that
Judgement Day has been and gone.
“August 29th, 1997, came and went.
Nothing much happened.
Michael Jackson turned 40.”
She then makes a few comments on humanity’s
future which you might recognize from the
final cut.
Fade to black; roll credits.
It’s far too tidy an ending and totally
unsuitable for the movie it’s supposed to
wrap up.
Then again, it wouldn’t have left much room
for a sequel either, which may not have been
the worst thing in the world.
A Grievous error
The showdown between Obi-Wan Kenobi and his
wheezing alien nemesis General Grievous was
one of Revenge of the Sith’s more entertaining
sequences.
According to a discarded animatic for the
scene, however, the fight almost ended in
the most ridiculous way possible.
The scene would have played out largely the
same, right up to the moment that Kenobi manages
to partially pry open Grievous' protective
chestplate.
Rather than getting cold-cocked and nearly
falling to his death, Kenobi would have finished
Grievous off by tearing out his heart with
his bare hands, casually tossing it aside
and blasting it with his sidearm.
Somehow managing to be both way too dark and
cartoonish at the same time, the very fact
that this scene was cut from the movie is
quantifiable proof that George Lucas is sometimes
capable of discarding bad ideas.
Not quite getting out
At the climax of Jordan Peele's masterpiece
Get Out, protagonist Chris Washington finally
escapes the grip of the nefarious Armitage
family.
As he barely restrains himself from strangling
Rose, his ex-girlfriend and pursuer, a police
car arrives.
Knowing nobody could possibly believe his
story, Chris prepares to be arrested, or worse,
but it's a fakeout.
The car is driven by Chris' TSA buddy Rod,
who helps Chris make good his escape.
In the movie’s original ending, however,
it really is the police who arrive, and Chris
is promptly arrested and taken to jail.
“I’m good.
I stopped it, you know?
I stopped it.”
Although it might have made for a more realistic
conclusion to the plot, Peele's decision to
give the beleaguered Chris a happy ending
seems like it was for the best.
Clerks’ last shot
Kevin Smith's 1994 debut feature is a largely
plot-free film which found most of its comic
mileage in the reference-laden dialogue of
its slacker leads.
It's a slight, sardonic work in which almost
nothing happens, which would have made its
alternate ending not only shocking, but completely
inappropriate.
In the original ending, Dante is closing up
the store after Randal leaves.
A man approaches the counter and Dante informs
him that they're closed, only to be shot dead
on the spot.
As the man cleans out the register, the movie
ends with a close-up on Dante's lifeless body.
Smith claimed that he shot this ending simply
because he had no idea how to end the movie,
but fortunately, star Brian O'Halloran, who
hated the sequence, was able to convince him
to cut it.
Thank goodness, or the film might not have
become the cult classic it is today.